[Music]
did you well you're gonna love this one
this is true because I I looked at the
article but did you see this
um
Jennifer Lawrence says a riff with her
Republican family was reignited over Roe
v Wade
she also has nightmares about Tucker
Carlson oh he's gonna milk that
he's definitely gonna milk that
he's got to right I don't want to
disparage my family but how could they
raise raise uh how could you raise a
daughter and believe she doesn't deserve
equality okay so hold on
um
why do they always post your elves on
purpose like that's my biggest question
in them always right does it seem to you
like they're always posting their L's
like on purpose because that's you know
where I originally found the article was
occupy Democrats I think posted it or
Facebook or something I think they post
their L's because they're wired a
different way now they like these people
think that they're victimhood
is like cool like it's you know what I
mean so it's like they just are always
posting their self owning neurotic
[ __ ]
hey nightmare it's about talking hey I
think he's doing do you think he's doing
the giggle hey Jennifer
one two Tucker's coming for you three I
think it's just him giggling though it's
that Tucker giggle as he's chasing her
I
and he's just chasing her asking her to
sign up for Fox Nation without even
anything violent
what's Dr Carlson today
he's just following her around what
about my documentaries yeah who's
watching these things are you because
I'm not
maybe it's your families
oh that's a good that was basically Nick
mullen's entire talker impression is and
it turns out there's naked pictures of
me on the internet who's jerking off to
this it's not me maybe it's you maybe
it's your family he uh if I'm Tucker
tonight
I would offer his family a free lifetime
subscription to Fox Nation on air there
you go show those documentaries
um so yeah that's where we are right now
we're at Jennifer Lawrence being afraid
hey Jennifer
I feel the need to remind you that I've
seen your butthole
it's amazing to me how many people
online have these want the opinions to
be respected whose buttholes I have seen
actually it'll actually blow your mind
how many people you could blow your
butthole it would it would it would I'm
just glad it's not Rob Reiner
um
first off your boy was in a daily wire
article so I want to thank Bull and
Branch sheets
I was in a daily wire article
daily wire did an article about the
Tucker Carlson Jennifer Lawrence thing
and they took some of the best Tweets
and took mine and uh Eileen him in
Photoshop I remember I had leaving me
Photoshop Tucker Carlson is Freddy
Krueger
for us uh so you know guys I'm selling
out I just want to say that bulletin
brand sheets is the best Sheets if
you're Jewish and want to have sex to a
whole
and uh what What's the gold one Birch
gold if you want to own gold but never
actually own hold gold in your hands
let them hold it for you you don't trust
Ben Shapiro
no wait why oh the Jewish thing because
because he's Jewish so
um
Tucker replied to the Jennifer Lawrence
thing that this is so good so Jennifer
Lawrence anyone surprised of course not
I was like there's dude there's only two
things I've been waiting for this week
number one I know in both of them are
number one was Tucker replying to this
and number two was dynamite and it looks
like Dynamite's gonna be [ __ ] ruined
because Dynamite sucks because uh aew
just suspended uh well their entire
roster right basically basically yeah
it looks like we're getting a lot of
dark matches tonight hey you know what
though I'm a big Dan House Fan so that's
good
friends let's go
anyway the second thing was Tucker
replying to this so here you go hey by
the way before you had pledge is gonna
say if you listen to Tony Khan and I
know you are yes you got to figure out
who you're gonna put this belt on next
yeah you know who's not getting in the
fights backstage one Mr daddy magic man
okay look let's [ __ ] world title run
bro I like him wanna take their titles I
don't I like him a lot but I don't think
he's right
um he is very good though anyway here
you go
when you decide to work in television
you lose control of a lot of things
foremost the way other people perceive
you so can it really be your fault are
you really responsible if major
Hollywood starlets dream about you
you know he's doing he's doing the AOC
thing this is so good and it's still
doing this I know the same thing with
Elon it's basically like why are you so
obsessed with me yeah exactly would
starlets dream about you
maybe it's the sexy glasses
[Music]
he's so thoroughly clown filled
highest paid person in news right you're
looking at him right now oh my God he
just turned into Chris Hayes yep or
Rachel Maddow yes
who knows we can only speculate Trace
Gallagher has the details for us though
tonight
Trace Gallagher yes he's gonna have
Tracy you bro you
yeah you pulled Trace Gallagher to do
this what was probably a very important
border story yeah
the cartels smuggling fentanyl inside of
children and you're like we need trees
let's get him back here we gotta talk
about butthole girlfriend what if
there's a connection
yeah
yeah and just so you get the total
dichotomy of this Tucker it's important
to note that while Jennifer Lawrence
sees you in her head at night you know
the nightmares when she sleeps she's
likely not watching you now but her
parents are probably watching you
because they're fast and it's true that
she said that in the van in the Vogue
article Jennifer notes in the October
issue of Vogue the 2016 election has
caused tension among her Kentucky family
quoting here I just worked so hard in
the last five years to forgive my dad
and my family and try to understand I'm
sorry forgive them for what for what for
voting differently than you yes you know
that I am actively friends with people
that don't vote like me right like
that's not like oh how do you do that oh
you what you do is you realize that the
real world is not Twitter and you act
like a human no I cut all those people
out of my life oh
I I can't be in the same room as a demon
rat well that explains all the cat
noises
hey all my cats are Republicans fair
enough no they do by the way that's the
title of murcia's next book it's gonna
be all my cats are Republican the Mike
Sheely story
the ballot Harvesters come here I write
down their names on the [ __ ] ballots
did he you'd be like you got to be
kidding me do you make cat jokes when it
happens that'd be great
hey uh what is your policy stance on
treats
are you Pro or against extra treats also
another question do you like needing the
same spot over and over again for no
reason
[Laughter]
and DeSantis is like look all right I'm
just here to run the state I'm not here
to tell individuals uh what treats they
can have or not have that's your freedom
that's your right can you can you please
tell us the merits of staring at a
corner in a room with nothing occupying
said corner but just swishing your tail
swishing your nails well I'll have you
know I have an affinity for cats as the
governor because I move my hands like a
cat playing with a string so that makes
sense
and they're like sir uh what is your
stance on licking your crotch until your
throat gets filled with so much pubic
hair that you cough up said pubic hair
to the floor and then begin licking the
pubic hair
and then ask Hunter Biden and then we
don't I don't take any of his good
answers and then we just write uh uh I
would just write a hit piece it's like
DeSantis Pro dog
it's the Santa's eating cats the Santa
runs the government and he's responsible
for the loud garbage trucks
cats are like oh you know what [ __ ] that
voting for Christ understand it's
different the information they're
getting is different their life is
different I'm sorry I'm just unleashing
but I can't by the way their life is
different yes they have to live every
day in their family home somewhere in
the middle of the country well you've
got to go to Hollywood and [ __ ] blow
Johnny up so like you know that maybe
other life is different maybe nothing in
politics will ever affect your life
negatively
and a lot of things can affect theirs
f with people who aren't political
anymore now as for her Tucker Carlson
tonight I can't f with people that
aren't political did you hear that
that's why the and there's an ignorant
statement but like the the opposite
should be true right like I can't [ __ ]
with people if they're not political
yeah I don't [ __ ] with people if they're
too political yeah nightmares they
likely stem from a 2017 segment where
you joked that she had Trump derangement
syndrome and where several media Outlets
you know what's [ __ ] funny it's true
that her parents watch Tucker and they
have to have seen Tucker dunking on
General her their daughter like every
time they tune in said that she blamed
Trump for a series of 2017 hurricanes oh
remember when she blamed Trump for
hurricanes that was fun now remember
this she was taken and I'm sorry uh
Jennifer but you're way off base on that
okay Trump wanted to literally drop
nukes on hurricanes yes that's the
difference she says grossly out of
context grossly really I mean shortly
after she said Trump would be the end of
the world and that Trump was a jar of
mayonnaise she went on to say in a 2016
interview with a British television
station that the election was quote
startling and quoting here you know
you're watching these hurricanes now and
it's really hard not to feel Mother
Nature's rage and Wrath
you know we have had one named storm yet
right maybe maybe one yeah we haven't
this year it must be it must be all the
climate change
and it kind of or maybe nature does
whatever the [ __ ] it wants that's why
that's why climate people are always
hilarious to me like they think that
they control nature and I'm like you
can't guys I know you think you want to
but you can't it's like thinking we
could control space exactly you can't
fix one ask Rage or wrath at home
exactly in 2017 it would likely have
been Trump and the deplorables but today
it would be Trump in the semi-fascists
or the rage and wrath is directed it's
just a guess
but it's a good one amazing so it's just
she says she has nightmares about us
that's what they're calling it now
nightmares yeah all right we're
flattered I think it's the sexy glasses
uh in either I think it's a sexy glasses
hey Trace Gallagher appreciate your
hard-hitting reporting on that subject
thank you
can't help but if they dream about you
he's just you're right you're right
because if out of all the people that
Jennifer Lawrence has met Tucker Carlson
is the one she should be having
nightmares right it should be Tucker
Carlson who should be scaring her right
out of all the people in her life that
she's ever been around Tucker Carlson's
the problem
she probably just has nightmares about
Weinstein and just replaces him with
Tucker Tucker yeah
I'll bet you money
bro of course at 100 and to him by the
way she's probably had a dream about
banging Tucker of course it was a
nightmare again she just replaced Tucker
with Weinstein um